Польсько-український кордон.
Східна межа Європейського Союзу.
Ми приєдналися до українських прикордонників.
Вони патрулюють вдень і вночі.
Близько п'ятисот службовців задіяні для контролю кордону з Польщею.
Однак він протяжністю близько 400 кілометрів, які важко захистити.
Незважаючи на паркан.
Євросоюз забезпечив українців обладнанням - відео- та тепловізійними камерами.
Таким чином ЄС допоміг посилити свій зовнішній кордон на Сході.
Євросоюз оплатив і паспортні сканери та подбав про єдину мережу,
яка зв'язує українських прикордонників з польськими колегами та з Інтерполом.
Спорядження теж щедро фінансує ЄС.
Прикордонник Галкін пишається цим.
Допомога ЄС дуже різноманітна.
Це може бути цільове фінансування для проведення капітальних ремонтів
або побудови наших будівель, службових приміщень, військових містечок.
Або це буде конкретна техніка.
Українські прикордонники повинні стежити за тим, щоб якнайменше біженців потрапили до ЄС.
Вони знову і знову затримують нелегалів, які прагнуть потрапити у Польщу.
Біженці не хочуть залишатися в Україні.
Як ця група, яка була затримана три тижні тому.
18 біженців, які приїхали з Ірану та Туреччини.
Вони безпосередньо через лінію українсько-польського кордону
на зеленій ділянці йшли пішки до Польщі.
Це були громадяни Ірану та Туреччини.
Відповідно їх притягли до адміністративної відповідальності,
вони сплатили штраф і були вислані з території України.
Україна безкомпромісно висилає біженців.
І це частина домовленостей з ЄС.
Та попри це кількість нелегалів зростає.
Цього року українська прикордонна служба затримала вже на 20% більше біженців,
ніж за минулий рік.
Це непокоїть чиновників.
Ми прогнозуємо такі ризики і бачимо їх, що це дійсно можливо.
У зв'язку з посиленням міграційних заходів в країнах ЄС,
ми прогнозуємо, що може відбутися перенаправлення потоків мігрантів з країн Африки
і з країн Азії через Чорне море чи через інші шляхи до України,
щоб потім потрапити звідси до ЄС.
Вже зараз пункти перетину кордону переповнені.
От уже понад рік українці можуть подорожувати без віз до ЄС,
їм часто доводиться годинами чекати у черзі на кордоні.
Бо, згідно з домовленостями з Євросоюзом,
прикордонники ретельно шукають біженців, які можуть ховатися в автотранспорті.
Якщо потоки біженців збільшаться, Україна матиме проблему.
Адже Київ проти побудови таборів для біженців, яких не хоче приймати ЄС.